that brings me to this next story uh
this is from azcentral
warrant issued for a warrant issued for
arrest of far-right streamer
tim baked alaska ginette after he
violates release conditions
fails to show in court now for many of
you you may not know who this guy is
many of you may but uh he's been
involved a lot in politics he used to
work for buzzfeed he then worked for
milo yiannopoulos
and uh i've actually interviewed him in
the past he was associated with
right-wing groups and then alt-right
groups and then argued that he wasn't
all right and then it goes back and
forth but the reality is i think what
we've learned from his time at buzzfeed
his attempt at being a rapper is that
he's actually just driven to get likes
he's driven to get attention on social
media and i think his story
and everything this guy's done he who he
was he's in he's filming himself
storming the capital he's pointing the
camera and he's like trump's going to be
really happy with us and he picks up
his phone or whatever and he's making
jokes he's gone
so far off the deep end there are a lot
of people right so
uh before we read into this i want to
mention joey salads right you guys know
joey sally yep yep we had him on the
show
he he made a youtube video where he
hired black men
to vandalize a car with trump support
like trump merchandise in it
and what he did was he was like i'm
gonna leave this this car with trump
supporters stuff in it
in this neighbor and see what happens
and the next scene is black men damaging
the vehicle
somebody in the apartment above filmed
it and saw what he
what joey had done and then right when
he released the video sent the footage
to i think h3h3 and then busted him
staging this attack which was and many
many people said it was racist or
fuelling racism whatever you want to
call it
and so i snapped at the dude i was
yelling at him i was like this is
disgusting behavior
but joey you know he apologized most
people just don't give him a chance at
redemption but i've always said if you
don't at least let someone
try to do better they won't they'll go
the other direction so i had a
conversation with him and
what he said to me what he said to many
other people is that he didn't realize
how far he had gone
in making this content and chasing after
the money and the views
now you look at someone like baked
alaska he's got no limit
it's all about the next one up to get
that hit to make that money to get those
likes to get that traffic
and then he winds up listen here's the
story i'll give the gist of it
he jumped bail according to azcentral to
go to dc in the first place breaking the
law
he breaks the law going in the building
and films himself doing it
and then he doesn't show up for court
and his lawyer can't get a hold of him
he has been driven to the extreme and
chasing after this night the crazy thing
he got started at buzzfeed ben smith the
former editor-in-chief
i believe was the one who hired him he
wrote an op-ed about it you take this
young person
you put him in this environment where
you're like get those likes get those
likes this is what buzzfeed's all about
get those shares get those shares
and they're gonna and i don't think
buzzfeed gets to uh absolve themselves
with the responsibility
of what they created in this dude well
if you look at the inner workings of
buzzfeed
they actually have entire walls
dedicated to how many licks
likes how many hits an article gets uh
don't look at me like that lydia
i know i did it was a fraudulent slip
but but they incentivized
potato potato they they incentivize i'm
polish and dyslexic
they incentivize literally uh get as
many hits as you can so is it fair to
say that that baked alaska is a product
of buzzfeed and buzzfeed radicals
yeah i i don't speak radical i'm not
trying to make a joke about it though
it's true
i don't think he is i think he was
already like that because even before
the whole capital thing i would actually
see some of his videos just on twitter
with the circulation it'll just be him
walking into like a grocery store with
no mask
and people telling him where to mask and
then he'll tell him like the buzzfeed
stuff was
years and years and years ago nobody
knew who he was when he worked at
buzzfeed oh yeah i know
and he gets hired for this job where
they incentivize his behavior bro
those things you do that shock content
you can make money doing it
in that system and like there's no
wonder that he right now like that
became his whole model well let's let's
read this so uh this from ac central
they say a scottsdale judge issued a
warrant for the arrest
of far-right social media personality
tim baked alaskagnet
after he said jeannette violated
conditions of his release by leaving the
state last week to go to washington
where he apparently live-streamed the us
capital riot
gina already was facing misdemeanor
charges of assault disorderly conduct
and criminal trespass in scottsdale city
court
after police allege he refused to leave
a bar and then pepper sprayed an
employee
he had been released in that case with
the agreement he not leave the state by
the court's permission
didn't he film himself doing that yes
yeah he filmed himself
on on on that d d live live stream yeah
pick up
somebody yeah picks up the picks up the
senate phone and acts like he's like uh
talking to donald trump it's just it's
all bad video so they say
judge james blake was not pleased the 33
year old jeanette chose to skip his
court hearing without explanation
and even janet's attorney zach thornley
was unable to reach his client on the
phone
during the court hearing now my
understanding is that d live banned him
yeah he is look i remember when he was
posting these like ironic nazi jokes on
twitter
and then he i interviewed him and he
said look it was just supposed to be
edgy and it was supposed to trigger the
left he was freaking out
and it was a mistake and i was like okay
and then he does it again and again and
again and then
then he gets banned he had like 250 000
followers
huge yeah and he gets banned because he
just would not stop
he was constantly trying to one up
everything so i was like okay dude was
clearly lying to me
now we see where he's gone since then it
is just a constant one-up
i tell you man when you're an addict and
you are chasing after that hit
i don't care if it's social media or
drugs this dude is now a fugitive from
the law
isn't it crazy how like we we talk about
social media being addictive how you
guys are mentioning that
luke you said it was like alcoholism
something crazier than that
here's a guy now who his lawyer can't
find him and the judge wants him locked
up
and he's probably he's probably facing
oh man federal charges for the right
this this warrant we're talking about
that's that's scottsdale arizona
that's arizona right that's not we're
not even talking about what's gonna
happen with the fbi
federal prison to own the libs no but
for the likes man
this is the important thing right i
don't think baked alaska is far right
i think he's just he's like a social
media saying whatever he can to whoever
will listen
yeah and social media prostitutes here's
here's what happened to a lot of people
on twitter
they would post a meme and if it was
like left or right probably right
because most memes are being produced by
the right right yeah
they get a ton of likes feels good a lot
of shares more followers more followers
so they one-up it and they chase after
it with
no end no point of self-reflection at no
point do they say hey whoa maybe that's
too much
like joey salads did only until he got
caught and shut down did joey realize
like i didn't realize what i was doing
and now he's stopped and now his videos
are like pokey pranks with his
girlfriend where like he's nicer
he puts like sprays with really quick uh
hey
attention is a hell of a drug yeah tim i
don't know if you ever
um or luke if you guys insinuate if you
guys heard of this uh social media girl
she was it was a couple years ago
her name was um because now that we're
speaking about this just
brings about time her name was little
tay and she was like yeah she was
she was like a 10 year old girl regular
girl and her brother
tried to groom her to be this like fake
social media
rapper and basically she would her
videos would be like you know you put
the camera on and she'd be like
i'm little tay i'm 10 years old and she
just have money she's like i'm rich this
is my ferrari
and she just got into it and then i
think i forgot what investigative
reporter
was able to pull the videos where her
brother is literally training her behind
a green screen like she's just like a
regular 10 year old she's like what do i
say
say like this be more ignorant and it
was just now now that we're speaking
about that addiction it was like
it was that too like they were just that
likes the likes that likes
fake images there was cases of of people
abusing their children
for youtube videos yeah exactly uh that
you know philip defranco even called out
and brought to everyone's attention that
was able to actually take them down
because if it wasn't for individuals
like like philip defranco to to actually
address this no one would have known
they would have kept growing in numbers
but he and i think a couple of his
viewers took all the videos and they
made a compilation
a compilation and it it was akin to
child abuse
of them putting their children from the
camera making them fight
doing everything for attention slapping
them hitting them i mean
it's just absolutely crazy how low
people will go there was a video on
youtube
of a dad giving his daughter a vaccine
be and like pulling her pants down and
putting the needle in her butt
and it had like 12 million views
i don't i don't it wasn't in america but
there was this phenomenon that happened
on youtube
where bots figured out what was getting
clicks
and created these insane videos of like
you'd see these cartoon thumbnails of
like a a guy drinking out of a urinal
and it's for real like a cartoon and you
click the video
and it's like what was spider-man joker
and elsa
running around with music and then elsa
was pregnant
and joker would have a gigantic syringe
because those were for some reason
what the algorithm was promoting so
these people are chasing after whatever
they can get
the algorithms are turning us into
lunatics yeah i look at i look
dude i get messages from people man i
don't know what's happened to my friends
no joke i have left-wing friends who
think
that i don't even want to get into the
conspiracy stuff they believe but it's
like
the you've heard of q anon you know why
because the media
talks about it and they go haha look how
dumb the right wings right-wingers are
but the right doesn't point the finger
at the fringe conspiracies of the left
and the things they believe
probably because that's not what the
conservatives do they're focused on
government they're focused on
power yeah but because the media is
focused on this this threat of q anon
they don't talk about the left and the
unhinged and insane conspiracies like
we got a glimpse of it when msnbc ran a
segment where they claimed that donald
trump was
a a soviet kgb asset
the soviet union no no joke from the 80s
they actually had a guy on it so we got
to consider that trump may have been
maybe an asset of russia going back to
the 80s
when they were part of the soviet union
dude now that was a glimpse
i tell you man i'm not going to name
some of these people because they got a
lot of followers hundreds of thousands
they've been on twitter the entire time
saying
insane things well beyond what q says
so you hear about this q and on stuff
and they'll be like the nighthawk is is
driving
and silver fox is gonna is gonna launch
the the missile and then we're gonna see
the indictments and it's like it means
nothing
and then you look at some of these
people on the left and they're like
murmurs are happening now the doj
you know uh they're turning they're
revolting the deep state is going to put
you know bannon on trial for treason and
he's going to be executed it's the same
thing yeah but the media doesn't talk
about it they give it a pass
well the mainstream media is now telling
us that the biggest threat for our
democracy for our existence
are people's individual political
opinion when in reality the threat is
the social media it's leading people to
hurt people it's leading people to
exploit people it's leading people to
break the laws
and just in those particular instances
that we noted here
there's so many more there's there was a
case in indonesia where people were
taking puppies
and putting them in horrible
predicaments and then rescuing them and
it was always the same puppy being
rescued after he was
placed there and they were manipulating
the algorithm which that was
incentivized promoted by youtube
just right now when you talked about
that vaccine case i remember seeing on
my
on my news feed looking up you know
stories for this particular podcast
i seen a vaccine proposal someone
getting a vaccine and proposing
on social media to get the likes and
attention
so when we look at the bigger threat
towards our existence
it's not people who say stuff on social
media that you may not like
it is social media that is the
existential threat
against humanity just ban all of it and
the crazy thing is ban all of it and ban
us whatever i don't care
humans have lost their minds this is
nuts yeah and i mean
the funny thing is it's not the funny
thing but it's just how media continues
to divide us and
i think i actually heard this yesterday
on on on tim's show yesterday was
the populace on the left and the right
agree on so much like if you just sat
them
at a dinner table they would literally
be shaking hands at the end of the day
like wow we could probably
take down the establishment but the
media makes it seem like we're so
divided like at the end of the day if
you grab someone from the left and the
right they say hey you know what
health care is screwing us over i want
to send my kids to college i want to be
able to work where i want i want to be
able to raise a family on maybe on one
income
we agree on these things but they're
making it seem like we are
are now like in a civil war we're two
different countries it's just i
mentioned this on the show yesterday we
were talking about the show recess the
cartoon
and i figured out who this guy was is
randall weems all right
so this is the it's a cartoon called
recess and it's about you know these
kids
an eclectic bunch a diverse bunch mind
you you've got
uh different races you've got the nerdy
guy you got the fat kid
and then like the regular kid or
whatever i don't know but there's this
one kid who would always
snitch to miss finster and there's a
quote hey
let me play or i'll make up something to
tell miss finster on you
and this kid's like hunched back and
he's like the teacher he's always you
know
rattling snitching on everybody that's a
journalist
that's journalist today all right what
they do is they see people posting jokes
and having a good time and they go
i'm gonna report you and then they call
they call someone at like a bank did you
know
that there's a guy on twitter who said
something dumb and he's got a bank
account with you
and then they're like uh we we don't
serve them anymore we're going to ban
them
shut down they're fun here's the best
part here's the best part
the show recess is from when i was a kid
right and so i look up this wiki for
recess
and randall weems age nine
however year of birth is 1988. he's 32
years old
that means he probably is at the age
where he would work at buzzfeed
so i'm telling you man these people
these journalists
are literally the randall weems of the
world we were all having fun during
recess playing kickball
some of us were really good at some of
us were bad at it some of us were the
weird loner kids who are hanging out
minding our own business or you were the
kid playing pokemon magic the gathering
and skateboarding
but he was the these journalists were
the nasty little tattletails
who were always sucking up to the
teacher and just getting in everyone's
way and everybody
hated them i wonder if you all know the
kind of person i'm talking about you can
think like oh man i remember that
i got one now they work at buzzfeed
carla
our journalists playing playing the uh
the snitch world but the journalists now
are playing the pr world where exactly
where now a politician would say
something and they just run with it like
what happened what happened to us
holding them to uh you know holding the
powerful accountable
now that we just do pr for them i don't
i'm not gonna say the msnbc's a host
name but as soon as
uh biden got elected she she went on
twitter and said oh isn't this a great
day
for america we finally have a president
who doesn't lie it's like you're
you're a news person yeah hold them
accountable so now
yeah so now journalists run run pr for
these people and he lied about the iraq
war so like yeah
yeah i mean come on biden is a bag of
lies no but if a politician is not lying
it's not a politician i'm sorry but luke
he he tweets black lives matter so it's
okay yeah again it's okay yeah it's fine
doesn't matter that that we bomb black
lives in the middle east as long as we
tweet it
that's okay you know it you know joe
biden is a lot of things
and it's funny because everything the
left says about
about trump you could point at joe biden
i'll give you some examples you know
what i mean oh but he's corrupt oh we
got china we got
ukraine we got the the bobby linski yeah
but trump is electric old man
hold on there well we got video after
video after video sleepy creepy joe
touching the little girls man
so look you can tell from the media and
i'm and i'm i'm i'm over
talking about it but i have to like let
me rephrase that
i'm sitting in my room you know i'm
doing research i'm reading the news and
there are stories that i probably would
have talked about a year ago
where it's like double standard in media
and i'd be like can you believe this
double standard now i'm like so what
it's life it's the new normal it's
possible we know the media is lying half
the time
more than half the time i mean come on
cnn just had john sullivan as a
correspondent
cnn brought on okay so cnn goes these
are insurrectionist domestic terrorists
now for our next guest one of the
demands a guy who was arrested for
egging them on and inciting the ride
and he's not a trump supporter he even
said he wasn't
and they have him on because they can
point the finger at the right and they
get away with it
that's creepy man yeah hey we're all
going to be waiting for that update on
cnn that they
interviewed uh a criminal punt i got a
feeling that update won't be coming
well thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time